i think the 2016 green is probably the
hardest ring i've ever seen won
it's probably the most meaningful
championship at least in my lifetime
yeah yeah i'm being honest oh yeah i
mean you guys beat the 73 and nine
warriors don't and no one ever even
gives a like that regular season didn't
mean [ __ ] because they didn't win the
ring
this is true
and i almost feel like
the the two rings after that like what
what did you want like i mean that was
four all-stars starting on the other
side of that i mean but you gotta
remember
at one point people were saying steph
was gonna be out the lead
like he had bad ankles i remember when
early on yeah
they was talking [ __ ] about this man
when he was winning all this [ __ ] he was
mvp that man was on a 40 million dollar
contract bruh it's crazy
they was done with him
and
this is the [ __ ] that'd be like this is
why
i got over them all playing together
cause i'm like bro no [ __ ] i
remember when they used to talk [ __ ]
about steph curry or clay thompson well
those guys the core group they all
drafted which is the one thing i can
never take away from the warriors
so it's hard it's hard to say they got
four all-stars they just
it's just the kd [ __ ] man they was just
whooping ass like and became also like
draymond green was one of them guys that
people
quote unquote say isn't an all-star it's
like bro he mean that much to them yeah
we knew in game five when that man
didn't play we saw how different they
was i'm like
bro no i won game five game six
if he plays game six do you guys think
you still win the ring
it'd be tough
they're a different ball club when they
went
there was a
like
it was like no [ __ ] it was like
coming up to the park and beating up on
some kids and they big brother just
ain't there right now
that's what it felt like it felt like we
just came up to the park and brushed our
last and y'all big homie wasn't here
and we beat y'all ass like we just beat
y'all ass y'all ain't do [ __ ] about it
now y'all now y'all calling dude you
gotta come back up to the park i love
this next game i [ __ ] hated the work
bro
the disdain for the warriors that i have
and then we won game six like you saw
the like concern and they faced they was
like man we do not want to go back to go
to state dealing with these people
because now they were just looking like
they was just defeated and now they look
like blood thirsty for a win like they
kind of felt the energy but
the cool thing about that whole [ __ ]
like
i don't think we would have
known that like draymond
what did he do hit brawn in the ball
yeah he kept flinging his leg like it's
crazy everything happened for a reason
because it's like bro we would have
never picked out how important draymond
was well also if we do that if we do the
what if game
kyrie is healthy in 2014 2015 you guys
probably have that ring as well yeah if
we're playing the what-if game and then
k.d with a cane of the cast
oh shout out to kevin durant i met him
with look he i know okay gonna be over
for this i gotta listen i gotta shout
out to katie because
uh